it's not panic buying if you've already
seen the food run out elsewhere
the people of beijing know what happened
in the lockdown of shanghai the food
shortages the government supplies that
when they eventually arrived arrived
rotten
they're looking after themselves because
they fear the chinese communist party
won't
[Music]
this is why they're worried three and a
half million people were ordered to take
pcr tests in beijing's biggest district
chao yang after a few dozen cases were
reported
this has never happened in china's
capital at this scale
and late on monday night the beijing
government announced that more districts
and millions more people would also
undergo mass testing and the people
should work from home this is the first
day of mass testing already the queues
are very long indeed snaking all the way
around here there's less about having to
go get the test more about the
uncertainty this could mean nothing life
continues as normal or it could be the
start of a lockdown here in beijing
and the fact that pictures like this
from china feel routine is extraordinary
when you step back
two and a half years into the pandemic
we have vaccines antivirals a mulder if
much more contagious strain of covid and
china is sticking to mass testing and
lockdowns
that approach did serve it well
initially and the government insists it
remains the correct one
the rest of the world may not seem much
to envy
china's stock markets recorded their
worst day since march 2020 amid the
darkest gloom of the initial wuhan
outbreak
and despite five weeks of severe
lockdown cases in shanghai are not going
down hovering at around twenty thousand
a day fifty-one people died from covert
nineteen a new record for the city
so there is no end in sight for that
lockdown beijing's fear their own
version is just beginning
tom cheshire sky news beijing